suppose we ask our Muslim friends why
did Allah reveal the Quran in Arabic
simple question right here they'll say
something like because Arabic is such a
rich language or because Arabic is the
perfect language for Allah to express
his
eloquence unfortunately for our Muslim
friends the Quran tells us exactly why
Allah revealed the Quran in Arabic and
Allah's reasons for revealing the Quran
in Arabic completely contradict What
Muslim today believe about the Quran
this is why Muslim Scholars never
discuss what we're about to discuss they
don't want anyone to know what you're
about to know if you think I'm
exaggerating watch this until the end
and explain to me how this information
isn't utterly devastating to dawa let's
set the stage for the problem by
recalling how these discussions about
the Quran arise our Muslim friends
invite us to convert to Islam and and we
ask why should we convert to Islam and
they say because it's the truth and we
reply but lots of ideologies claim to be
the truth why should we believe that
Islam is the truth and they say because
of the Quran it's so masterfully written
it must be the word of God now even
before we open the Quran and start
reading we can spot an obvious
difficulty with this wonderfully written
argument Romeo and Juliet was
wonderfully written the brothers karaza
was wonderfully written the Love Song of
Jay Alfred proofrock was wonderfully
written what in the name of Common Sense
does all this wonderful writing have to
do with whether these works are the word
of
God as far as I can tell absolutely
nothing but we're trying to be nice so
in spite of the absurdity of the claim
we open the Quran anyway and we find the
worst most boring most disorganized book
we've ever red in our entire lives
terrible beyond our already low
expectations so we go back to our Muslim
friends and we tell them as politely as
we can the Quran is less interesting
less impressive and less enlightening
than a phone book and that's when our
Muslim friends pull the ultimate trump
card from the bottom of the desperation
deck they say well it only works in
Arabic here we start wondering if if
Islam is the religion for all people why
would the main evidence for Islam only
work in one language a language that
most people do not speak even native
Arabic speakers can't understand much of
the Quran because it's written in
classical Arabic but it gets worse
because even classical Arabic Scholars
can't understand parts of the Quran the
Arabic scholar gett pu for instance says
this the Quran claims for itself that it
is mubin or clear but if you look at it
you will notice that every fifth
sentence or so simply doesn't make sense
many Muslims and orientalists will tell
you otherwise of course but the fact is
that a fifth of the quranic text is just
incomprehensible this is what has caused
the traditional anxiety regarding
translation if the Quran is not
comprehensible if it can't even be
understood in Arabic then it's not
translatable people fear that
and since the Quran claims repeatedly to
be clear but obviously is not as even
speakers of Arabic will tell you there
is a
contradiction the Iranian scholar Ali
Dashi in his book 23 years adds the
Quran contains sentences which are
incomplete and not fully intelligible
without the aid of commentaries foreign
words unfamiliar Arabic words and words
used with other than the normal meaning
adjectives and verb verbs inflected
without observance of the Concords of
gender and number illogically and
ungrammatically applied pronouns which
sometimes have no reference and
predicates which in rhymed passages are
often remote from the subjects these and
other such aberration in the language
have given scope to critics who deny the
quran's
eloquence so we're supposed to believe
that the Quran is from God because of
its Clarity and eloquence when experts
tell us that it's hopelessly unclear and
not very good at all this is where our
Muslim friends jump in and tell us don't
trust the experts trust the daag guys
who say that the Quran is the most
amazing book ever yes the daag guys
those honest and dependable Boy Scouts
who assured us that the Quran has been
perfectly preserved but later admitted
that it was all a lie the daag guys
those upright and credible do Goods who
assured us that the Quran is filled with
miraculous scientific insights but later
admitted that it was all a lie the daag
guys those Compulsive Liars who assure
us that the Quran is supernaturally
eloquent and must be from God and we
just have to believe them we just have
to take their word for
it notice we're supposed to convert to
Islam because of the supernatural
eloquence of the Quran but how are we
supposed to know that the Quran is
supernaturally eloquent when we don't
speak Arabic what our Muslim friends are
really telling us is this we either need
to trust what the dawa guys say about
the Quran without understanding the
evidence for ourselves or we need to
spend years studying classical Arabic so
that we can perhaps find the evidence
for ourselves someday so we can either
accept what the daag guys say about
their book without investigating or we
can spend Years Learning another
language so that we can eventually
invest tigate the matter on our own why
is this a problem it's a problem because
it completely contradicts the
Quran and you're about to see how here
goes according to the Quran Allah has
sent prophets to every nation in Surah
16: 36 of the Quran Allah says and
verily we have raised in every nation a
messenger proclaiming serve Allah and
shun false gods
don't forget what Allah says here a
messenger a rasool was sent to every
nation to guide people similarly in sah
10:47 we read and for every nation there
is a Messer and when their messenger
cometh on the day of judgment it will be
judged between them fairly and they will
not be
wronged so Allah sent a messenger to
Every Nation but the the Arabs were the
last to receive guidance which is why
Muhammad was the last of the messengers
how do we know Muhammad was last let's
find out in Surah
36: 2-6 Allah declares I swear by the
Quran full of wisdom most surely you
Muhammad are one of the Apostles on a
right way a revelation of the Mighty the
merciful that you may warn a people
whose father were not warned so they are
heedless do the math here a messenger
had been sent to every nation but the
people of Arabia hadn't been warned
we'll go ahead and ignore the fact that
according to the kurran Abraham and
Ishmael were in Mecca where they built
the cabba I guess they just kept quiet
while they were in Arabia constructing a
house of worship no Warner to the people
of Arabia before Muhammad but Every
Other Nation had its messenger Surah 34:
43-44 and when our clear Communications
are recited to them they say this is not
but a man who desires to turn you away
from that which your fathers worshiped
and they say this is not but a lie that
is forged and those who disbelieve say
of the truth when it comes to them this
is only clear enchantment and we have
not given them any any books which they
read nor did we send to them before you
Muhammad a Warner no Warner before
Muhammad sorry Abraham and Ishmael Surah
32:3 or do they say he has forged it nay
it is the truth from your Lord that you
Muhammad may warn a people to whom no
Warner has come before you that they may
follow the right dire rection so a
messenger had been sent to every nation
but no messenger had come to the Arabs
and this is why Allah sent Muhammad once
Muhammad had been sent to the Arabs the
last people to get their messenger Every
Nation had been warned as we read in sah
35: 24 surely we have sent you Muhammad
with the truth as a bearer of good news
and a Warner and there is not a people
but a Warner has gone among them
according to the Quran Muhammad was sent
to warn his people Arabs other groups
had their own Warners and the Quran is
clear that when Allah sends a messenger
to a group he sends a messenger who
speaks the language of that group sah 14
verse4 and we sent not a messenger
except with the language of his people
in order that he might make the message
clear for them so that's why Abraham and
Ishmael didn't warn the people of Mecca
wrong
language here's where you should start
to see a problem for the Muslim view of
Muhammad if Allah only sends a messenger
who speaks the language of the group
he's sent to how can Muhammad be the
messenger for the entire world did
Muhammad speak English and Russian and
Spanish and Mandarin and
Swahili no then according to Allah he's
not the messenger for people who speak
English or Russian or Spanish or
Mandarin or
Swahili Allah specifically says in Surah
42:7 that the Quran was revealed in
Arabic to warn the Arabs who lived in in
and around Mecca and thus have we
revealed to you Muhammad an Arabic Quran
that you may warn the mother City Mecca
and those around it and that you may
give warning of the day of gathering
together wherein is no doubt a party
shall be in the garden and another party
in the burning fire it's an Arabic
Revelation for people who speak Arabic
Surah 4 4: 58 verily we have made this
Quran easy in thy tongue in order that
they may give heed Allah made the Quran
easy for who people who speak Italian no
in thy tongue in your language why in
your language that they may give heed
they who Arabic speakers Surah 43: veres
2- 4 by the book that makes things clear
we have made it a Quran in Arabic that
you may be able to understand and learn
wisdom and verily it is in the mother of
the book in our presence high in dignity
full of
wisdom Allah made the Quran in Arabic so
that people who speak Arabic can
understand it if you don't speak Arabic
it's not not for you Sarah 26: 192
through
196 and most surely this is a revelation
from The Lord of the worlds the faithful
Spirit has descended with it upon your
heart that you Muhammad may be of the
Warners in plain Arabic language and
most surely the same is in the
scriptures of the
Ancients Muhammad was one of many War
Warners he's the Warner in plain Arabic
language but he brought the same message
that's in the scriptures brought by
other Warners in other languages sorah
41:
2-3 a revelation from Allah the most
beneficent the most merciful a book
whereof The verses are explained in
detail a Quran in Arabic for people who
know think about this for a
moment Allah says he revealed the Quran
in Arabic so that Muhammad could warn
the people in and around Mecca he
revealed the Quran in Arabic to warn
Arabs but why did the Arabs need a
revelation in Arabic there were Jews and
Christians in Arabia and according to
the Quran Jews and Christians had
reliable scripture from God the Arabs
could have simply listened to what Jews
and Christians were saying about their
books so why did the Arabs need a book
in their own language Muslims today will
say because the scriptures of the Jews
and Christians were
corrupted here again that's not what the
Quran says the Quran affirms the
inspiration preservation and authority
of the scriptures of the Jews and
Christians the Quran according to Allah
confirms previous scriptures in Arabic
Surah 46: 12 and before this Quran was
the book of Moses as a guide and a mercy
and this book the Quran confirms it in
the Arabic tongue to admonish the unjust
and as Glad Tidings to those who do
right the Quran confirms previous
scriptures in the Arabic language so
that Arabs will know that these books
are the word of Allah see how this works
if you were a 7th century Arab and you
saw Jews claiming that they had a book
from God how would you know whether to
believe them you don't understand Hebrew
how would you know if their book is from
God you would know because Allah gave
you a book in your language that
confirms the books in other languages
according to the Quran it makes
absolutely no sense for Allah to reveal
a book to a group of people unless that
book is revealed in a language that the
people understand Surah 41 verse
44 and if we had sent this as a Quran in
a foreign language other than Arabic
they would have said why are not its
verses explained in detail in our
language what a book not in Arabic and
the messenger in
Arab according to the Quran if Allah
hadn't given a revelation in Arab Arabic
the Arabs would have had an excuse for
not obeying Allah Surah 6: 155 to
157 and this Quran is a book we have
revealed blessed therefore follow it and
guard against evil that Mercy may be
shown to you lest you say that the book
was only revealed to two parties before
us and we were truly unaware of what
they read or let you should say if the
book had been revealed to us we would
certainly have been better guided than
they if a book isn't revealed in your
language you're just not responsible for
following the book so did Allah reveal
the Quran because all other Revelations
had been corrupted no that's a Muslim
myth Allah revealed the Quran so that
Arabs wouldn't be able to complain that
they didn't have have an inspired book
in their own
language the position of the Quran then
goes something like this Allah sent
Messengers to every nation and he
inspired scriptures for different groups
of people these scriptures are reliable
and authoritative for the groups they
were revealed to as of the early 7eventh
Century Arabs didn't have a revelation
in their own language but these Arabs
couldn't simply trust what Jews and
Christians were saying about the Torah
and the gospel how would Arabs know if
Jews and Christians were telling the
truth so Arabs needed a revelation in
Arabic that's why Allah sent
Muhammad now that Arabs have the Quran
they can read the Quran other groups
have their own books in their own
languages this is why Allah in the Quran
orders Jews and Christians to follow
their own scriptures not the Quran in
Surah 5:43 some Jews come to Muhammad to
settle a dispute how does Allah respond
how come they unto thee Muhammad for
judgment when they have the Torah
wherein Allah hath delivered judgment
for them notice what Allah says Muhammad
Why are Jews coming to you when they
have their own book they don't need you
you're the messenger to the Arabs not to
the Jews Surah 5: 68 say oh people of
the book Jews and Christians ye have no
ground to stand upon unless you stand
fast by the law the gospel and all the
Revelation that has come to you from
your
lord Jews and Christians are supposed to
follow the revelations that came to them
they're supposed to believe in Muhammad
they're supposed to believe in all of
the messengers but they're supposed to
live by and judge by the revelations
brought to them by their
Messengers Allah sent a messenger to
Every Nation people are responsible for
obeying the messenger who was sent to
them speaking their
language that's the position of the
Quran why is it a problem for Muslims
well here goes our Muslim friends tell
us that the Quran is the book for all
people and that the Quran can only be
understood in Arabic but the point of
revealing the Quran in Arabic according
to the Quran itself was for people to
have a book in their own language so
that they wouldn't have to learn another
language to understand the word of Allah
the Quran was revealed in Arabic so that
a particular group of people the Arabs
in and around Mecca would have a
revelation in their own language so that
they could understand it for themselves
according according to the Quran if
Arabs didn't have a revelation in their
own language they'd have an excuse on
Judgment Day they'd be able to say Allah
you can't blame us for not obeying you
you never told us what to do in a
language we could understand Allah
didn't want them to have an excuse so he
sent them a revelation they could
understand in the language they spoke so
we've read the passages Allah himself
says how can I make this any clear ER
I'm giving Arabs a book in their
language because they can't just trust
what Jews and Christians are saying
about their books and I can't expect
Arabs to spend years learning Hebrew or
Greek so that they can examine the Torah
and the gospel for themselves people
need a revelation in their own language
and if they don't have one they'll have
a legitimate excuse on Judgment Day I
can't allow that so I'm revealing the
Quran in Arab Arabic for Arabs that's
what Allah
says but what do our Muslim friends tell
us what do the dawa guys tell us they
tell us that we all need to live by and
judge by the Quran a book revealed in a
language we don't speak and don't
understand they tell us that we either
have to just believe what they say about
the Quran or we have to spend Years
Learning a language we don't speak
this is the exact opposite of what Allah
says about why he revealed the Quran
this is precisely what Allah says he was
trying to avoid Allah says that he sent
Messengers to different groups in
different languages so that people could
understand his commands in their own
languages Muslims tell us the exact
opposite they tell us that we all have
to obey a book in a language we don't
understand if you read the Muslim
sources you'll find over and over again
that our Muslim friends completely
contradict their own God their own
prophet and their own book why because
they have
to Allah told them that he sent
Messengers to every nation and that each
group had to judge by the revelations in
their language but Muslims eventually
checked the books of other groups and
realized that they didn't line up with
Islam the obvious conclusion to draw was
that Allah and Muhammad had no clue what
they were talking about but Muslims
couldn't say that because that would
make them apostates and you know what
happens to apostates in
Islam so they started lying they said oh
contrary to what Allah clearly says in
the Quran all other scriptures have been
corrupted and everyone now has to judge
by the Quran the book Allah says he
revealed so that people wouldn't have to
follow a book in a language they don't
understand and and once they started
lying they couldn't stop which is why
they lied about perfect preservation and
scientific Miracles and Muhammad in the
Song of Solomon and it's a religion of
peace and Muhammad was a feminist and
Aisha was actually 18 and so
on dawa is deception there is no plan
B the weird part is that the dawa guys
psychologically condition their
followers to only listen to them and not
to listen to Allah and
Muhammad if you don't believe me here's
an experiment you can
perform go to your Muslim friends and
show them what Allah says about why the
Quran was revealed in Arabic your Muslim
friends won't care even slightly they'll
just go to their favorite dawa guy who
will tell them no the Quran is the book
for all people in all languages and all
other books have been
corrupted and your Muslim friends will
believe their favorite da guy even when
he contradicts
Allah Islam isn't the religion of
submission to Allah it's the religion of
submission to Compulsive
Liars if you'd like another example of
the daag guys saying the exact opposite
of what their God and their prophets say
be sure to watch my video what the Quran
really says about the gospel where I go
through every single verse in the Quran
that so much as mentions the gospel but
somehow can't managed to find a word not
one word about the gospel being
corrupted strange how the da guys expect
us to take their book seriously when
they obviously don't take their own book
[Music]
seriously